auf und davon mit der Mobiliar
Versicherungen und Vorsorge
[Applaus]
wo sie stehen
[Musik]
auf und davon viele wollen es nur wenige
Tuns
letztes Jahr haben wir Auswanderer bei
ihren Abenteuer begleitet wie geht es
Ihnen heute wir haben sie erneut besucht
Marina Mara und maikostettler eröffnen
nach heftigen Startschwierigkeiten
in Florida einen waffelshop bald schon
arbeiten Sie über 100 Stunden in der
Woche Mike er leidet einen Zusammenbruch
[Musik]
jetzt ist Mike wieder zurück im Geschäft
und er konnte sich einen weiteren Traum
erfüllen
[Musik]
Bauernfamilie Wiese zieht an die
französische Atlantikküste
[Musik]
sie übernehmen einen Hof mit 400 Tieren
von einem Tag auf den anderen werden sie
zu einem der größten Milchproduzenten
der Region
ein Jahr später Frankreich leidet unter
einer jahrhundertüre auch der Hof unsere
Auswandererfamilie ist betroffen
[Musik]
Sommer in der Toskana im Agriturismo von
Eva dudle und Philips
Eva gibt das auswanderungsprojekt auf
[Musik]
Philipp und Eva können sich zwei Jahre
als sie das Abenteuer Auswanderung wagen
Ihr Projekt ein bäuerlicher Gästebetrieb
mit sechs Ferienwohnungen samt
Swimmingpool und 18 Hektar Land
die beiden Pensionäre werden zu jung
Bauern Philips erstes Projekt ist ein
Olivenhain
[Musik]
ein Olivenhain mit 800 Beinchen
philipp ist weiter Mathis Vermächtnis in
der Toskana
nach einer schweren Krankheit ist der
knapp ein Jahr nach seiner Auswanderung
verstorben
es ist nun sein Freund Alfonso Gianni
der sich um die Bäumchen kümmert
das ist perfekt
der Olivenhain war Philips
Herzensprojekt
dabei hatte es so schön begonnen
[Musik]
im Frühling 2021
Philips mit einer großen Vision im
Herzen in die Toskana als Gutsverwalter
des Agriturismo muss er erste
Vorbereitungen treffen
die Liebe zu Italien hat Philipp im Blut
seine Großeltern stammen von hier er
kennt die Mentalität und sein
italienisch ist perfekt
[Musik]
um als Agriturismus zu gelten müssen die
Zürcher Landwirtschaft betreiben Philipp
lässt 800 Olivenbäume anpflanzen
während in Italien Philipp die
Verantwortung trägt arbeitet die
kapitalgeberin Eva in der Schweiz weiter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
Kinder haben Evas ganzes Leben bestimmt
nicht kindergartenlehrerin und selber
Mutter von sieben Kindern
[Musik]
die Rentnerin ist froh weiterhin Geld zu
verdienen
[Musik]
Schweiz
damit die Olivenbäumchen perfekt
anwachsen können muss Jungbauer Philipp
die jungen Pflanzen bewässern
Julio der Sohn seines Freundes Alfonso
hilft ihm dabei
sind im Ganzen sind 800 Bäume also sie
[Musik]
schnittliche bestrafen
[Applaus]
während der Sommerferien ist auch IFA in
die Toskana gereist die Zürcher sind auf
Einkaufstour
[Applaus]
neue Vorhangstangen für die
Ferienwohnungen
Gutsverwalter Philipp bringt die
Bescheinigung dass sie eine Firma
besitzen so können Sie gewisse Ausgaben
steuerlich absetzen
[Musik]
Sommer 2022 auf dem Hof der
Bauernfamilie Wiese im französischen
b-dula
es ist heiß und trocken die Natur leidet
unter einer historischen Dürre
wer kann flüchtet in den Schatten
[Musik]
auch Bauern Sohn Jan hat ein Plätzchen
gefunden
[Musik]
die Bäume und Sträucher sind einem
enormen Stress ausgesetzt um zu
überleben werfen einzelne schon jetzt
die Blätter ab
eigentlich leben die wiesers in einer
wasserreichen Gegend doch jetzt sind
Teile der Loire praktisch ausgetrocknet
während Wochen durften die Bauern nur
nachts bewässern jetzt ist auch damit
Schluss frankreich hat den Notstand
ausgerufen es gilt ein absolutes
bewässerungsverbot
ja weil wenn ich jetzt davon
Hitze die Bauern haben oft besucht
seit ein paar Tagen ist Sohn Sascha mit
einem Freund da
sie vergrößern den Schattenplatz für die
Hühne
es kommt in dieses zugute dass sie für
ihre 400 Kühe nicht nur Mais sondern
auch Gras angebaut haben
[Musik]
die Wasserleitung die Sandro für die
nächtliche Bewässerung extra angelegt
hatte muss er wieder zusammenpacken
gut am Rand ist sicherlich nicht so
wirklich
aussagekräftig aber
die Ernte an eine Dürre verlieren das
hätte sich Sandro wohl kaum vorstellen
können als er vor über einem Jahr kurz
vor dem Auswandern stand
in der Schweiz bewirtschafteten die Visa
seinen kleinen Hof mit 50 Kühen
hauptberuflich war Sandro in der
Finanzbranche tätig der Hof war sein
Hobby
dass sie es investierte Kapital
ausschließlich Landwirtschaft betreiben
und zwar gewinnbringend
dafür sind sie bereit einen Teil der
Familie zurückzulassen
tschüss
[Musik]
alles Gute
getroffen und
mit der Konsequenzen
ja
Hobby
ihre neue Existenz der Hof lesupé im
Frühjahr 2021 wechseln 359 Tiere der
futterbestand und die
landwirtschaftlichen Maschinen ihren
Besitzer
[Musik]
im hofeigenen Büro wird überschrieben
in dieser Million Euro noch nicht
inbegriffen sind die Gebäude das
Wohnhaus und das
Grundstücken Geschichte
[Musik]
unterschrieben und notariell beglaubigt
der riesige Hof gehörte nun den
Schweizern
[Musik]
vor 20 Jahren sind Alexandra und Sandro
ein paar geworden
alles war perfekt sie heirateten doch
ihre Geschichte hat einen Bruch
nach sechs Jahren ließen sie sich wieder
scheiden doch gerade mal zwei Jahre
später verliebten sie sich erneut und
heirateten zum zweiten Mal
also
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
gut 6.500 Liter Milch gibt seine
Holstein hier der täglich der
Vorbesitzer des Hofs Bad
Resorts drei Angestellten geworden 30
Jahre war er Besitzer jetzt muss er
Sandros Neuerungen mittragen statt um
6:30 Uhr wird neu um 5:30 Uhr gemolken
[Musik]
Tampa in Florida unsere Auswanderer
Marina und Mike haben eine neue
Leidenschaft Stand up Paddling und sie
haben sogar Zeit dafür
letzten zwei Jahre wenn du nochmal
schaffen schaffst einfach dass der
Körper mein geschrieben macht
funktioniert und vor dem herrlich
momentan sicher schöner zum Leben
[Musik]
lange hat das Glück einen großen Bogen
um sie gemacht
und Zeit dieses wertvolle Gut war den
beiden komplett abhanden gekommen
zuverlässige Angestellte halten Ihnen
nun den Rücken frei
der Crystal River knapp eine Stunde von
ihrem Zuhause entfernt ist das Reich der
menitys der Seekühe harmlose
Riesenviecher
dass die beiden ihr Leben in Florida
endlich auch genießen können dafür
brauchten sie wahrhaftig Stehvermögen
aufhören wäre zweifellos einfacher
gewesen
hier fing alles an Reichenbach im
Kandertal war eher zu Hause hier führte
Mike nebenberuflich ein Tattoo-Studio
das war einmal
seine große Leidenschaft
Amerika
endlich kann der Traum
wahr als Franchise nehme wollen sie in
Tampa einen waffelshop eröffnen
drum Amerika kommt mehr von Mike aber
für mich
bleiben
[Musik]
bestens vorbereitet verlassen die beiden
ehemaligen Polizisten kurz vor der
corona-pandemie die Schweiz
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
im Norden tempas in einer ruhigen
Wohngegend hissen sie die Berner Flagge
doch kaum haben sie amerikanischen Boden
unter den Füßen bricht die Pandemie aus
die Welt ist plötzlich eine andere ihr
Traum kommt gehörig ins Trudeln
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der Umbau ihres waffelrestaurants kommt
kaum vom Fleck gleichwohl laufen die
Kosten weiter Inventar Versicherungen
Haus und lokalmiete auch die
visumsverlängerungen sind deine
Zitterpartie denn die
Einwanderungsbehörde arbeitet nur
reduziert
ursprünglich glaubten die beiden dass
sie ihr Lokal zwei Monate nach Ankunft
eröffnen können doch nach fünf Monaten
ist der waffelshop
immer eine Baustelle seit Wochen
verlieren sie täglich Geld
positiver
[Musik]
zurück in die Toskana schon kurz nach
der Auswanderung trennen sich die
Zürcher wieder deswegen das Agriturismo
aufgeben kommt nicht in frage sie werden
zu Geschäftspartnern
ihr Gästebetrieb ist noch nicht
offiziell eröffnet als sich unverhofft
schon erste BesucherInnen anmelden eva
ist überrumpelt schließlich fehlen in
der Küche noch Töpfe und Geschirr
Touch wenn Sie
es gibt nur so viel zu machen wie es dir
keine Ahnung
nur in dieser Wohnung ist die Küche
schon eingebaut
ist in seinem Element
hier in Italien kann er auch Gastgeber
sein
Gastfreundschaft steht bei ihr an
oberster Stelle
und für mich gilt das dass ich für mich
da ganz wichtig ich wollte ja
ich werde wirklich
machen wo Leute
ich finde man sollte
da bin ich wohl
[Musik]
auch der Sommer 2021 ist trocken
wochenlang regnet es nicht würden die
jungen Bäumchen nicht bewässert sie
würden die heißen Monate kaum überleben
noch dürfen die Zürcher den
Wasserspeicher einer Nachbarin anzapfen
trotz der Nachbarschaftshilfe den
Zürcher ist sehr wohl bewusst dass sie
dringen deinen eigenen
Grundwasserbrunnen brauchen
denn ihre Quelle ist versiegt sie müssen
zehntausend Euro zusätzlich in die Hand
nehmen
sie lassen sich von ihrem Treuhänder
beraten
dazu kommt um den Status Agriturismo
nicht zu verlieren müssen Sie weiter in
die Landwirtschaft investieren sonst
drohen habige nachsteuern
noch mehr Land urbar machen hieße Leute
anstellen das kostet einen Kredit
aufnehmen empfehlen der Treuhänder und
Philipp
doch das kommt für Eva nicht in Frage
ich muss nachher auch
und wenn ich Schuld gerade
trotz des Alters noch einmal
durchstarten die Zürcher haben die
Aufgabe sicherlich unterschätzt
dank ihrer Lebenserfahrung weiß Eva aber
auch wann sie aufhören muss
sie verabschiedet sich von Philipp und
entscheidet sich das Agriturismo
aufzugeben
[Musik]
auch Gutsverwalter Philipp muss
Abschieden nehmen
wenig später erkrankt Philipp schwer und
reißt in die Schweiz zurück
Philipp stirbt im Kreise seiner Familie
[Musik]
Sommer 2022 eva ist noch einmal in die
Toskana zurückgekehrt es tut mir sehr
leid
und
ich kann erlaubt wie Jungen
sehr mitstreit und und auch sehr
wirklich Mitglied danke
einfach gemerkt wie er eigentlich
und
ja
[Musik]
emotional hat sich Eva schon vor
geraumer Zeit von ihrem gemeinsamen
Projekt auswandern verabschiedet
nun will sie das Agriturismo verkaufen
[Musik]
und
von
ich meine Familie da das ist
[Musik]
zum letzten Mal Ferien im Agriturismo
der Nonna in der Toskana auch eine
Freundin ist extra angereist eva ist
froh ihre liebsten bei sich zu haben
da muss man einfach dauern Knopf machen
und dann abschneiden ja
das Agriturismus soll in diesen Tagen
den Besitzer wechseln
auf dem Hof lesobje hat Bauernsohn Jan
Glück den Swimmingpool hatten die visas
schon vor Wochen gefüllt
im Büro kauft Sandro einem Nachbarn 300
Tonnen Mais ab
[Musik]
[Applaus]
11.000 Euro ein unerwarteter Budget
posten
[Musik]
2021 freuen sich die Wiese über eine
ausgezeichnete Ernte
die Arbeit macht dem ehemaligen
hobbybern riesig Spaß
[Applaus]
für den Schweizer ist es wichtig seinen
Tieren genügend Gras verfüttern zu
können denn Gras ist proteinhaltiger als
Mais
die Bauern gönnen sich kaum eine Pause
und oft wird es fast Mitternacht bis die
Maschinen stillstehen
in der Schweiz silierte Sandro 300
Tonnen Gras wir sind es fünfmal so viel
nebst 4000 Tonnen Mais
[Musik]
und das bin ich drin
und im Moment erlaubt es einfach nicht
dass ich jetzt irgendwie zwei Wochen
irgendwie
sind so viele Sachen am laufen die wir
kommen
aber sicherlich nicht ja und lauter will
Geld
machen ja
[Musik]
definitiv und ich weiß nicht drauf
um den nachwuchsauflösung
[Musik]
so hat es Alexandra in der Schweiz
gelernt fast jeden zweiten Tag kommt ein
Junges zur Welt
6 Liter Milch kriegt jedes halblieben
der braucht extrem viel Kraft aber nicht
schön
noch schleppt sie die schweren keinen
selber das Taxi leer hat sie erst
bestellt mit diesem elektrischen
Milchwagen wird die Fütterung der Kälber
einfacher werden
[Musik]
Frankreich
das ist das ganz ganz andere Welt eine
Neuanschaffung haben sie bereits in
Betrieb genommen den automatischen
Futter Anschieber
günstigste Mitarbeiter
durch den Roboter spart er nicht nur
Zeit seine Tiere bekommen auch mehr
Futter und somit steigt der Milch Ertrag
die Ideen gehen dem Schweizer Bauern
nicht aus
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
Freude der Landwirtschaft kostet
erträumt hast das ist es danken die
Generationen es ist danke Jahreszeiten
[Musik]
Monate verspätet endlich nimmt Mike und
Marinas American Dream wieder Fahrt auf
sie feiern die Eröffnung ihres
waffelladens
[Musik]
Schreiner dann jahrelang Polizist und
nebenbei Tätowierer
und
von
kurz vor der Eröffnung noch schnell die
Soßen aufrühren
mit dem Bohrer
[Musik]
trotzdem punktgenau um 5 Uhr
setzen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
zum ersten Mal serviert Mike eine Waffel
als eigenständiger Unternehmer
zum laufen bringen aber er hat das
endlich verstanden
die Waffeln finden Anklang Marina und
Mike Arbeiten bald 14 Stunden täglich 7
Tage in der Woche europam
doch der große Erfolg hat seinen Preis
[Musik]
Mike er leidet einen Zusammenbruch wie
aus dem Nichts hat er eines Tages
Panikattacken kann nicht mehr
Burnout der Arzt verordnet ihm sofortige
Ruhe und Medikamente
Blutdruck ist massiv ob sie nicht
und das mit sehr schlecht und
[Musik]
im waffelshop trägt Marina die
Verantwortung allein
[Musik]
keinen
E-Mail eine Zeit voller Unsicherheit
lange ist unklar wann Mike ins Geschäft
zurückkehren wird
[Gelächter]
aber es ist schon mega Herausforderung
Schweiz
und das hat ist angezan anbracht und es
hat mehr angebracht zumindest ja
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in diesem heißen Sommer an der
französischen Atlantikküste
Ferien kennen die bauernleute nicht
[Musik]
doch beim Schlemmen im Messung und
deklusier kommt zumindest das Gefühl auf
schon morgen reist Sascha wieder nach
Hause der 22-Jährige ist oft zu Besuch
bei den Eltern bereits das fünfte Mal
ich nehme
20 Minuten
[Musik]
der kleine John lernt früh das Abschied
nehmen zum Leben gehört
[Musik]
Sommer 2022 mike ist schon früh auf den
Beinen nicht wegen der Arbeit
alina ist eine Tochter aus einer
früheren Beziehung
[Musik]
die Fahrt ist kurz 10 Minuten bloß
e
Erfolg
der Frau
die Torten Springs High School
1800 Schüler besuchen Sie die 15-Jährige
Schweizerin ist nun eine von ihnen
innerlich hatte Eva ihr
auswanderungsabenteuer schon lange
losgelassen heute soll es offiziell sein
Ende nehmen
ja
so Gott will wirklich
nicht mal einen Monat war das Podere das
Agriturismo zum Verkauf ausgeschrieben
und Evas marklerin hatte einen valablen
Interessenten gefunden
den Verkauf wickelten die Maklerin und
der Treuhänder ab Eva will nur
unterschreiben müssen
die Möbel bleiben hier ausgesuchte
Bilder sind im Preis nicht inbegriffen
oh ja könntest du mir bitte die
Bilderrahmen
ja und dann muss man Plastik mit dem
Rössli von Natur aus tatkräftig und nach
vorne
schauendelt Eva bereits mit einem
kleinen gut in Frankreich
schon einmal wurde die
Vertragsunterzeichnung verschoben heute
soll sie gelingen
[Musik]
im Haus der florida-auswanderer sind nun
alle Bewohner wach
Marina ist ein Familienmensch ihr
gefällt das Alina eingezogen ist
[Applaus]
im
Alltagsdingen und
ja vergesse ich eigentlich machen und
mit deren
und schön die Unternehmer beschäftigen
zurzeit 7 teilzeitangestellte die
entlasten
vor acht Monaten hat Mike sein
Tattoostudio hier in Amerika eröffnet
weniger im waffelshop Stehen dafür seine
Passion Leben das Tätowieren das half
Mike in seine alte Form zurückzufinden
die Erfahrung der Krankheit aber bleibt
ein Teil von ihm
ja sehr gut sehr
also körperlich geht es mir wieder sehr
gut
und
ja
und und persönlich und aber vielleicht
Menschen
e
die Hündin
ist mit ihnen ausgewandert
die Katze hat Marina aufgelesen und
aufgepäppelt Baghira ist ein
vollwertiges Familienmitglied geworden
also
geschrieben
und ja sehr schön gesagt
[Musik]
im Agriturismo warten Eva die Maklerin
und der Treuhänder auf die Käufer
dass die Vertragsunterzeichnung schon
einmal kurzfristig verschoben wurde
macht sie nervös
tzeit
einer halben Stunde sollten die Käufer
hier sein
[Applaus]
drei Hamburger wollen die neuen Besitzer
des Agriturismo werden
hallo ich bin Thorsten ich bin Eva hallo
im Frühjahr waren die Deutschen zum
ersten Mal hier das Agriturismo hatte
ihnen auf Anhieb zugesagt
endlich hier doch noch einmal gehen Sie
auf eine Runde
[Musik]
es geht um viel Geld
weniger
eine Woche oder zwei Wochen ist der
findet die Fliesen schön
finde
überdachte Terrasse da draußen
die ruhige Lage des Anwesens und seine
Nähe zum Meer das hat die deutschen
überzeugt
[Musik]
lange haben sie in Frankreich auf den
Regen gewartet für 2000 Tonnen Mais kam
er zu spät
der Ernteertrag ist jetzt in den
flach-silos eingelagert 1000 Tonnen Gras
und 850 Tonnen Mais
bei der Mais
im Normalfall
mit der trächtnisverbot
mit einer blauen Augen
mit einem Zukauf konnten sie einen Teil
davon wieder wegmachen
[Musik]
trotz schlechter Ernte die Schweizer
Glauben an eine Zukunft in Frankreich
die 25-Jährige Melkmaschine soll durch
eine Roboteranlage ersetzt werden dann
entscheiden die Kühe wann sie gemolken
werden wollen
so können Arbeitskräfte eingespart
werden
auf lesobje wird bald die größte Anlage
der Region stehen
[Musik]
und ja meine die Investitionsvolumen da
sind die sind das sind Hypotheken wo man
jetzt
klar
und was natürlich extrem hilft ist im
Moment was läuft denn man merkt also
Installation weil das ist die letzte
wegen des Melkens früh aufstehen gibt es
dann nicht mehr
[Musik]
John lernt das Bauern von der Pike auf
Jan soll auch mit der Aufzucht der
Kälber vertraut werden
[Musik]
danke
Alexandra genießt die Zeit mit dem
jüngsten Sohn
[Musik]
zwei Monate
über die kleinen nähert sich Gian
langsam den großen an vor den
ausgewachsenen 700 kg schweren Kühen hat
der zehnjährige noch gehörigen Respekt
[Musik]
Tochter Alina ist in der Schule Papa
Mike und Marina öffnen Punkt 11 Uhr den
waffelshop
die Angestellten übernehmen das Geschäft
im Laufe des Nachmittags
Folie
und
ja aber meine Angst glücklich schätzen
schaffen
amerikanischen
[Applaus]
Gelassenheit Mike kann noch einiges von
Marina lernen
[Applaus]
Dezember
Fußball
[Musik]
amerikanisches Geschäftsmodell
funktioniert
Ben Browning war Mikes erster
amerikanischer tattoo-kunde
die beiden haben sich im waffelshop
kennengelernt und sofort verstanden
wenn's Körper bietet einigen Platz für
Mikes
[Musik]
ready
Tätowierungen gehören zu bandsgeschäft
er ist Leadsänger einer heavy metal band
[Applaus]
ja
i think we Store just someone
[Gelächter]
mike hat Glück er konnte sich auch im
Shopping Center zwei Minuten vom
waffelshop einmieten
[Musik]
in Italien ist die Unterschrift gesetzt
der Kaufvertrag gültig
Nummer vielen Dank dass du das so
gepflegt übergibst weil das anders aus
vielen Dank weil wir haben das Projekt
gekauft
zu sein weil wir das alles noch
staubsaugen und alle fliegen wegputzen
weil ich bin eine Schweizerin und das
kann ich nicht
ruckzuck und die Deutschen müssen weiter
diesen feierlichen Akt beschließen wir
mit dem Schlüsselübergabe des poderes am
Vorrat Elemente
ciao
[Applaus]
und mit diesem Akt beendet Eva ein
weiteres Kapitel ihres Lebens
[Applaus]
dass sie ein Agriturismo in der Toskana
besaß ist somit Geschichte
[Musik]
eine wechselvolle Geschichte eine
Geschichte in der sich Traum und
Realität nicht finden konnten
und ich habe
das finde ich eigentlich mega gut die
Erkenntnis
und von der bin ich nicht
auf mich verrückt dass ich jetzt
irgendwie die Erfahrung gemacht das soll
ich bedanken
abgemacht dass das nicht als 6 Stunden
vor der Schweiz weg
bestimmt
Eva wird nicht jünger ihre Abenteuerlust
jedoch scheint ungebrochen
[Musik]
in Frankreich ist dann einem Fußballclub
beigetreten dem ASR maskul der
Mannschaftssport hilft in der neuen
Heimat Fuß zu fassen
Mama
[Musik]
natürlich extrem neugierig Franzosen
natürlich mit der Schweiz bleiben
[Musik]
keine Freizeit hat heute der Vater
der unermüdliche mache ist einmal mehr
am optimieren
schaffen sich einen neuen mistschieber
an
der Alter hat seine Tücken und bleibt
immer wieder hängen bei 8.000 Kubikmeter
Jauche im Jahr muss der funktionieren
permanent ich programmiert überall
scharfe das verstehe ich nicht
die Kühe sind Familie wiesers
Lebensgrundlage ihnen darf nichts zu
stoßen
[Musik]
ich
verdiene
super gemacht
die besten aber auch nicht
[Applaus]
john ist nicht nur auf dem Hof leobier
angekommen er hat in Frankreich auch
Freunde gefunden
[Musik]
trotz der Freude am waffelshop etwas hat
Marina spätestens in den USA gelernt
Veränderungen können unangekündigt und
plötzlich kommen
ein weiteres amerikanisches Standbein
wäre gut
und Marina hat auch schon eine neue
Geschäftsidee
[Musik]
und dann bin ich interessiert
eigentlich virtuellen Assistent über
eine eigene Homepage möchte sie Firmen
kaufmännische Dienstleistungen und
Inhalte für deren soziale Medien
anbieten Aufgaben die sie während der
letzten zwei Jahre täglich für den
waffelshop macht
weitere Angestellte wie Restaurant
Managerin Maddie sollen das baldmöglich
machen
schon am frühen Nachmittag Schluss
machen das liegt heute schon drin
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
an der Taten Springs High School ist
jeweils um 14 Uhr Schulschluss die
Austauschstudentin Alina kommt mit dem
Bus nach Hause
[Musik]
obwohl hier beim Papa alles cool und
easy ist schnell hat sich die 15-Jährige
in den USA nicht eingelebt
hallo
[Musik]
ihr Englisch muss Alina noch verbessern
bestimmt bereits gelernt aber hat sie es
lohnt sich nicht sofort aufzugeben
vielleicht hat sie das beim Vater
abgeschaut
heute geht es in der Norden der Stadt
nach Port Richie
hier gibt es die legendären tiki-bars
der Besuch einer solchen Bar ist ein
Mast
ein weiteres Mast ist der Mückenspray
ohne Spray geht man in Florida nicht ans
Wasser
[Musik]
die Verbundenheit mit der Familie war
für Marina schon immer wichtig in den
USA hat sich dieses Gefühl noch
verstärkt
reden
[Applaus]
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der waffelshop war das Ticket zu ihrem
amerikanischen Traum
heute hat Mike zudem ein Tattoostudio
und auch Marina will bald neue Pläne in
Angriff nehmen es scheint die Schweizer
haben ihren amerikanischen Traum noch
lange nicht ausgeträumt
[Musik]
vielleicht wird John Farmer in Kanada
das Rüstzeug dazu bekommt er ein
Frankreich
sein Papa lässt ihn heute zum ersten Mal
den futtermischer lenken die größte
Maschine auf dem Hof 11 Tonnen schwer
ist sie
zwar langsam
super
das Auftanken der Maschine ist Teil der
heutigen Aufgabe
wichtig ist dass man
locker 34
alles will gelernt sein auch das
akribische Führen des tankbüchleins
ja dann ist motiviert doch was immer er
künftig machen wird an Selbstvertrauen
soll es ihm nicht mangeln
[Musik]
denn wenn nur schon die Eltern an einen
Glauben ist alles möglich
[Musik]
auch die Auswanderung seiner Eltern ist
geglückt und ist damit ein gutes
Beispiel dass sich Träume erfüllen
können
[Musik]
ihren auswanderungstraum in die Tat
umsetzen das wollen auch Anita Tommy und
aller ärgerte mit über 60 Schildkröten
und Schlangen wandern sie nach
Griechenland aus
ihre Idee Ferien für Reptilienfreunde
anbieten
aber das Schicksal hat einen anderen
Plan ein verheerender Waldbrand legt ihr
neues daheim in Schutt und Asche
[Musik]
ist der auswandertraum von Anita und
Allah damit gescheitert
balkenständigkeit und mehr Zeit
miteinander das sucht Familie Rotzler in
Schweden soll der Wunsch Wirklichkeit
werden
sie kaufen eine Ferienanlage mitten im
Wald
[Musik]
viel Gerümpel
die Anlage auf Vordermann bringen wird
zur Herkulesaufgabe
bleibt da noch Zeit für mehr
Familienleben
und auf und davon nach Kanada
so schön so schön auf Prince Edward
Island Glauben Barbara hasenböhler und
Thomas Range noch etwas bewegen zu
können
ihr riesiges Anwesen wollen sie in ein
exklusives Gästehaus verwandeln
doch alles verzögert sich
[Musik]
als der Umbau endlich läuft bricht sich
Barbara einen Knöchel und fällt aus
[Musik]
trotzdem rechtzeitig eröffnen können
wenn ich happy in der Situation nein bin
ich nicht
die neue Staffel ab 6 Januar auf SRF 1
[Musik]
auf und davon mit der Mobiliar
Versicherungen und Vorsorge